do-don't evite dinner per doctor that
did it there a bit bad no good evening
I'm poppy Moria and welcome to Mary ham
news our first story comes from Jo Jo
see wa jo Jo Siva is a youtuber with
over almost 10 million subscribers I'm
pip why does this exist well it turns
out that in Jo Jo see was products it
was contaminated for the second time
with asbestosis would Jo Jo zebra has
products that cause cancer what
not only does hurt content cause cancer
now her products does as well
jo Jo see WA was like my pillar of trust
how could she break it like this with
the Frick Jo Jo see why I trusted you
I've always said so juicy well I can
trust no matter what i buy all my merch
and make a products from her but those
of you don't know asbestos it's usually
finding fiberglassing like isolation of
houses insulation it's very not good to
breathe in that stuff that can give you
cancer and other illnesses very bad
thing cost cancer to your fans not good
okay
so she'll release this apology video
apology video time let's watch
are you serious are you freaking serious
this [ __ ] you do not give up
that you do not have the right to give
up that smirk Jojo all right and I'll
get don't get me started with the ironic
side left side I'm getting very angry
you know nothing says genuine apology
video like disabling the comments and
uploading it on your second channel yay
let's make sure as few people as
possible know about this I can't do that
gonna start this video all serious and
dramatic but that's not who I am that's
not what this video is about it's just
this video makes me this video is just
pure pain to watch so I'll just skip to
the end you can get a refund at no
matter what it is if it's used if it's
onion get a full refund also I can still
use it
it has asbestos in it but I can still
use it that's great
I got asbestos for free wow that's so
nice Thank You Jojo see what thank you
to be fair play devil's advocate maybe
this is one of those things where God
I'm trying to think maybe this is one of
those things where it sounds bad but it
really is not that big of a deal this is
the only way I can defend this I don't
know and I don't care to look into it
because I'm Mary ham and research that's
for [ __ ]
next news update update news update
nerves get excited for Update news team
few verses face cleanser on my update
yay I really want to know more about
this please tell us yes I will I will
okay calm down
Kieffer's lawyer has spoken out in an
interview previously what we know about
the faze clan vs t few lawsuit was the
fact that face client kept saying oh we
tried to just give him like an updated
coupon track but he just said no he
doesn't want to be part of face he just
like he doesn't want to be part of it he
said he's so unreasonable like why does
he not just negotiate with us well
apparently as it turns out through t
pers lawyers that they did they try to
give a legal version of the contract to
them which face client then adjusted so
much in the sense that it became illegal
again faithlyn was presented with the
contract turner would accept it was you
know as close to a legal contract and
you can get but parent
that wasn't good enough for them and
they decided to mark up about half of it
get rid of about half of it put in their
own provisions which again made it
illegal
once again obviously this is interesting
because it changes sort of what was the
dynamic as what was said but at the same
time what their version of the conduct
could have been easily as unreasonable
to face client as basic alliance
contract to tea whew
so it could be whatever yeah in the end
it could it doesn't even matter
another point that was interesting that
was brought up was there's sixty
thousand dollars that face Klein had
only taken from T few and that was it
that's all they taken but the lawyer
brings up well he's actually brought
them in so much more money just from
being in face thousand dollar figure as
to what they made off him it's
disingenuous I mean you realize how much
money
today's plan is making by having Turner
as part of its team how much advertising
they're selling how many sponsorships
that they obtain because Turner was part
of their team it's almost laughable to
think that they are saying that they
took sixty thousand dollars from him and
that's it when they've made millions of
dollars okay alright it's a good point
right that's why phase wants to have t
feel part of face to begin with so that
they can make money um its clout his
epic fortnight cloud smash like if you
were like fortnight but then again if he
makes him that much money through brand
deals then why the hell did he only make
sixty thousand from it right or what's
20% I mean math help me sixty times X X
times X times zero twenty three hundred
thousand that's my mad TV's only made
three hundred thousand for through brand
deals from face coin alright next dodgy
veggie versus ksi drama that this has
been some of the hot this drama in a
very long time like no no one cares
about this even me try to figure it out
I'm like okay
all right well then G upload a video
yesterday or two days ago it's very
emotional okay so how did we end up here
well let me summarize for you instead of
watching one like five hours of content
three weeks ago today G K sighs brother
uploaded a video saying that he's tired
of seeing as the bad guy and he uploaded
this video called by and he's like my
brother is not that great okay the main
gist of the video was that he felt like
his brother didn't sign up for him his
brother didn't have his back and that
he's done a lot of shady stuff as well
have you back no matter what family
sticks by you then ksi responded to this
videos here for you whether we're on
good times or bad terms whenever you
message me I always replied edge I want
you to succeed in everything you do but
Dad you man you have to communicate with
me to me this video seemed pretty
genuine he addressed all my I think all
the issues that desi brought up about
the girl drama that happened apparently
Capeside slept with a girl that did he
liked some drama that happened during
Christmas who [ __ ] cares that day G
is always getting punched in his videos
or something like that and they do
respond to saying okay moving on great
great thank God just solve this
privately like why was this video made
to begin with I would be a lot more
inclined to pick the G side in this
situation if this original video didn't
have a bunch of minerals on it it's a
45-minute video very much in the same
style as the Tati call out James Charles
video that was gaining so much traction
if it wasn't for these two things I
would be more inclined to believe the
AG's intention with just wanted to stand
up for himself he keeps saying that I'm
not attacking case I am just standing up
for myself that my intention was not to
attack him but you are bringing up a lot
of things about your brother
to make him look bad you don't have to
do that to defend yourself not all of it
is that way but a lot of it is you can
stab someone and say I'm not trying to
hurt you well that doesn't change the
fact then deggi uploads a fourth video
wearing the exact same outfit what have
you been tuned for the past two weeks
Tajiks you're surprised edgy oh my god
in this video daddy says that a yes huge
evidence saying that caves I lied about
the girl thing because the case I said
can yes I said he didn't know who the
girl he slept board was actually someone
his brother knew oh my god he straight
up I'm gonna show you some huge evidence
that will just make you question the
whole of my brother's video I didn't
even know she knew you I don't even
remember your name even being mentioned
for all I knew she was just a girl that
I met at a concert I didn't even see her
in any of your videos so this is case I
saying that he knew the girl was on his
channel but that doesn't prove that he
knew that they were together but then
again ksi look at this I have evidence
never remember your name even being
mentioned ball I news he touch his nose
that's like a classic example of lying
ksi liar confirmed this happened what
three years ago two T two years ago is
2016 I don't remember what I did
yesterday help me please it just seems
so stupid all of this did you guys not
listen in my totty video stop bringing
private things into public then that he
showed against so bizarre that he shows
a the text message between her and this
girl because he thought she gave him an
STD oh this is someone else sorry Deji
it's writing fu man to a girl made me
sick you dumb F how are you gonna meet
me then tell me you're sick honestly F
yourself I ain't meeting you anymore I
don't trust you you could have given me
an STD don't be word I'm sorry sad face
sad face I only started feeling ill that
day when I was on the way up sad face
sad face f off you're a real piece of sh
do you have an STD cuz I swear what of
course I don't good sad face go away
what the hell is this I met this girl
right she did she have a cold
I didn't know she had a cold I wish she
had called the next day and I thought
she gave me an STD I was pissed
that's why I said all the Miche I said
oh my god I got a cold I thought you had
an STD then it gets very emotional and
very intense
despite daddy's flaws I do like him in a
way he's he has over here you have some
likeable qualities okay I hate to see
him like this I think this has clearly
gone too far Deji
please take a break you'll be fine it's
time to take a break from YouTube this
is it's not a good idea in one way you
know he's the one that made the first
video he's the one that started all this
out of nowhere
and it shows again how bad of an idea is
to bring these private matters into the
public eye a lot of people seem to think
like oh yeah people just do all this
crazy stuff to start drama online and
like it's gonna be epic they get so much
views yes they get views from it but
clearly it's taken a massive mental toll
on Deji and I do feel them for that and
I think I hope he realizes to just stop
this no one cares who's right and wrong
at this point I don't just it's time to
drop it I will not be talking about this
anymore this is just stupid at this
point I think it shows a it's a fatal
flaw with the YouTube book pal
you know numbers start dropping and you
feel like you have to do something and
then at the end was it worth it I don't
think so next news doctor disrespect did
something disrespectful what
unbelievable
so doctor disrespect did an IRL stream
on they eat through floor he was very
much in character making fun of people
at the site
[Music]
then doctor disrespect did the
unthinkable
he had very hot poopoo and needed to go
and make mud pies diarrhea honey can we
find the diarrhea place
and he filmed inside the bathroom so
here's how that footage looked like
by
ladies a jump I gotta take a diarrhea
grab that
[Music]
this cause doctor disrespect of getting
banned from twitch that's right
everybody so it is against the Community
Guidelines I think on twitch website it
says that sharing content that violates
another reasonable expectation of
privacy from for example streaming from
a private space without permission
should this doctor disrespect been
banned yes I don't think anyone is
arguing against he clearly went against
the rules
I and that's just how it is I've seen a
lot of people's picking some sort of
moral high-ground of going I can't
believe I can't believe doctor
disrespect did this obviously I
understand that's people want bathrooms
to be a private space and that that
should not be violated I'd get it at the
same time I don't see the baby it's sort
of like the mean with boys locker room
what do people think happened in the
boys locker what if someone saw
someone's penis I have never seen a
penis in a boys locker room or a men's
bathroom okay unless you specifically go
slow and you're not gonna receive some
peanut peepee a lot of people have been
saying well there was a kid there was a
kid in one of the urinals
oh well checkmate liberals kids aren't
allowed at e3 maybe you should try and
ban him instead huh oh it's illegal to
film in a bathroom okay all right but
let's look at the law number of six four
and seven which everyone brings up this
is the one everyone talks it's illegal
it's illegal okay well what does it say
privacy exists basic existing law
generally makes a person who looks
through a hole or opening into a
periscope telescope camcorder camera in
a bedroom bathroom changing room pin
room blah blah blah blah blah blah with
the intent to invade privacy of a person
is guilty of misdemeanor with the intent
was it doctor disrespect intent to
invade the privacy of a person in there
I think that's arguable maybe I'm not a
lawyer so I have no idea what I'm
talking about from this footage of this
it's just following him into the
bathroom stall it's not trying to show
other people this is what I got about
out of it was it a bad idea I was
Lee should he have gotten banned I guess
so that are those are the rules
was this the worst thing that has ever
happened I don't think so
that is not for me to say I think other
people should do this I'm just looking
at the context of this I don't see it as
that big of a deal to act so outraged
about okay
it seems more like people are insecure
about their schlongs being shown on
camera for some reason and me Mary hem
don't care no insecurities about sling
songs our final notes comes from pita
who made this tweet love the new hash
tag Pokemon Rule ooh great well my new
favorite Pokemon is ruined thanks Peter
they have a special message for all
their future trainers I'm not your ruler
sweater this is a meme template waiting
to happen and of course Shadow the
Hedgehog unbelievable my wool grows back
anyone is welcome to take my wool sheeps
have to be sheared they don't shed like
most animals shearing doesn't hurt them
at all they enjoy it well done Peter
well done that was it for all the uber
tease this week Peter pie no see smash
like subscribe check out the merch guys
very epic we got the nude Suki merch
that's right we launched beanies in the
summer what are you what are you not a
hipster check out represent com support
the channel namaste limited time epic
lateness we have t-shirts now what you
never played super simulator you know
it's fun right I'm not supposed to give
my opinion but give it a try and then
you can tell me if it's good or not not
convinced yet okay I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]